ich habe sogar mal in der schule
spanisch in der zehnten klasse habe ich
mit nach zwei beendet und dann hat die
lehrerin mir gesagt ja also überlegte
das mahlgut das weitermachst wirst jetzt
gab's guck mal sagt gracias a dios
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video ja leute ich hoffe
natürlich geht es gut wir können uns
direkt 110 jugendliche und zwar haben
wir heute mal wieder eine nach sehr
langer zeit eines macbooks sie haben die
mir sogar noch vor weihnachten so
geschickt led ersten videos dazu nicht
gesehen haben das sind also boxen
da sind immer verschiedene süßigkeiten
drin oder ja eigentlich schon süßigkeit
oder auch getränke aus verschiedenen
ländern also wir hatten schon irland
hongkong
was waren denn noch dabei die usa
greifen
zum teil waren genau so weiter ja auch
noch und ich habe jetzt von den wieder
was neues bekommen
diesmal aber das schon reingeguckt
deswegen muss ich jetzt hier kein
geheimnis was man hat das ist was ganz
besonderes und zwar zum ende des letzten
jahres moment an weihnachten haben wir
dies mal was ganz besonderes für euch in
dieser snack und bin ich ein bisschen
spät dran auch nicht in dieser snack box
findet ihr genau die snacks und
süßigkeiten die in den letzten monaten
am meisten gefeiert hatte sie kommen aus
der ganzen welt und machen damit eure
adventszeit zu einer ganz besonderen
also wir haben jetzt die beliebtesten
süßigkeiten aus dem letzten jahr in
einer auch gleich werde ich das eine
oder andere davon schon kennen es sind
natürlich süßigkeiten aus der ganzen
welt aus ganz vielen verschiedenen
ländern
allerdings habe ich auch erst vier
videos zu diesen boxen gemacht das heißt
wir werden wahrscheinlich auch noch eine
menge sachen drin sein die ich nicht
kenne
zum beispiel diese hier die chemie schon
oder
wir hatten so fade melonen irgendwie mal
einfach immer wie groß sie sind
das ist der hammer es ist nicht der
abend von hasel halten mehr
ja nein ernsthaft ich dachte oh ne
scheiße war das wie ein hase mit
goldberg ja dann hängst du komplett klar
wenn man eins und eins zusammenzählt
aber warum sollten die aktie habe ich
trottel alter das habe ich ja gar nicht
gesehen aber in deutschland nicht
deswegen einen komischen nachgeschmack
haben sie wahrscheinlich max
ich bin gar nicht mal so schlecht was
sollten die leser dieser kleine front
bei süßigkeiten kraft jubel immerzu
abschloss hier steht das leider gar
nicht bei aus welchem land sie kommen
weil in deutschland gibt es ja definitiv
nicht habe ich zumindest bis jetzt noch
nicht gesichtet aber kein problem wir
machen weiter das kenne ich zum beispiel
auch nicht hier haben wir nie fingers
das sieht schon gut aus oder snowy
fingers körper in might & magic öffnet
damit jetzt wirklich mal gespannt wie
die aussehen also so was habe ich noch
nie gesehen viel zu probieren
schmeckt ein bisschen wie ein und
ausstiegs umgeben von schokolade nehme
ich zwei kritisch aber nicht gut nicht
gut kommen wir zum nächsten produkt also
das kommt wahrscheinlich aus asien
irgendwo karamell korn
ach so das ist praktisch ist
wahrscheinlich so ähnlich wie popcorn
mit karamell geschmack ich stelle mir
das jetzt ganz verrückt vor und dann
kommt auch noch aus asien weil die haben
da es einen ganz eigenen style hinaus
wie friedrich malta dass ich mit so
einer fabrik oder so immer aber ich kann
mir richtig vorstellen was ist in asien
ein richtiger trend
schmeckt wie viel preis auf einmal preis
kennt man ja lebt gesalzen probleme
einkommen wegen in denen ein und ein
kanzler kohl hat ja genug so was du was
deine meinung dazu nicht ein blogger
können wir mit dem rest steht sogar den
namen drauf also ich muss sagen würde
ich mir jetzt niemals privat kaufen weil
es irgendwie also es schmeckt schon ein
bisschen irrt aber es ist eine erfahrung
halt so was probiert zu haben und wie
ich eben schon gesagt habe ich glaube
dass es in asien richtiger renner
wo auch immer das verkauft wird kannst
du weißt du was das für ist dass china
oder sehr gut was haben wir noch das
scheiß der alter kitkat in kombination
mit orio jetzt stellt sich die frage ist
das eine wirkliche kooperation oder
haben die sich einfach gedacht wir
machen da mal diese oreo kekse einmal
cookies und grüne sind wahrscheinlich
keine echte hieß ja also ich glaube von
ist wahrscheinlich von kitkat wo kommt
das her
das sieht irgendwie so freuen dass sie
zu norwegisch aus der fiel dann kam die
malaysia aus malaysia
[Applaus]
als echt manchmal sachen ich frage mich
also eigentlich finde ich diese videos
bei ich weiß sie aus erfahrung kriegen
eigentlich zu viel zu wenig
aufmerksamkeit für die sachen die man
zeigt weil eigentlich ich würde das so
einschätzen das interesse so was mal zu
sehen allein schon die eigentlich
ziemlich hoch ist oder aber es
interessiert sich ja nicht viele leute
von meinen zuschauer noch für diese
videos arbeit machte trotzdem weil sie
mir spaß machen abonniert den kanal
falls sie nicht schon die eine million
recht ich werde mich nicht von dieses
video kommt ok und hier haben wir guck
mal das ist auch ein bisschen dunkler
die das komische losgeht war das ist
schon echt richtig lecker ich stelle mir
das gerade im eis vor ist so ein
vanilleeis hast mit fressen wie bei
macquarie und da kommen dann so stücke
davon rein also das ist bis jetzt auf
jeden fall das beste mega okay du bist
immer noch nie hier kenne ich schon
die haben wir noch nie gehört ich glaube
schon dass ich die mal öffnet haben doch
ich habe die auf jeden fall für andere
mal gesagt ja das ist nämlich jetzt
nochmal eingepackt und hier drin sind
dann so komische keine ahnung was das
sein soll dass nur ein tier sein das
hast du garantiert noch nicht gegeben da
sind rentiere genau
doch ich habe jetzt aber da schon
wirklich die gleichen willkommen die vom
weihnachtsmann aber die gehen ja auch so
ein bisschen in die richtung kitkat also
ich weiß nicht ich würde sogar sagen
steht ja sogar mini rentiere steht hier
vielleicht wo die herkommen steht ja
nicht aber gut leute jetzt bin ich
wirklich gespannt
gebt euch mal das was ist das denn das
kommt aus spanien oder portugal oder so
es klar dass schokolade langkow contra
melodie kubi dann kommt das lokalkolorit
intelligentes la quinta babbel euro so
lasse ja das ist aus barrien
chocolaterie karamell
machen wir das mal auch wird das auch
aber das gerade gesagt ist verlieren die
italiener spanier ist jetzt da css des
schlafens erste la casita du chocolat
ich habe sogar mal in der schule
spanisch der zehnten klasse habe ich mit
einer 2 beendet und dann hat die
lehrerin gesagt ja also überlegt dass
man gut aber das weitermachen sagt
gracias a dios
wieso gehen dass hier nicht auf das gibt
auf jeden fall der kammel lass dich da
steht so wie bei gold drauf echt geil
schmeckt wie smarties mit extrem
intensiven karamell geschmack gut und
weiß nicht also bis jetzt bin ich echt
begeistert von den sachen aber es sind
natürlich auch nur die besten der besten
jetzt haben wir hier noch sieht aus wie
sein alter sieht eigentlich aus wie eis
kommt wieder aus ich würde mal schätzen
südkorea oder so oder alt waren fragen
wir nicht wo bei teilwahlen kann's nicht
sein sonst würde ich das nämlich schon
kennen die haben wir noch etwas
ähnliches kann man hier vielleicht
spricht einer der zuschauer die sprache
ja leute wenn ihr wisst wo das herkommt
schreibst auch gerne in die kommentare
doch doch doch das ist erst mit dem race
tippen
das hat mir doch nicht wir hatten das
glaube ich mit den fertigen form schon
dann hat ihr wahrscheinlich schoko
vanille und erdberg und dann gibt es
hier diese dinge die kannst du hier
reinstecken und das wird dann oder soll
dann gleich ein eis werden weiß ich ob
ich das jetzt rausnehmen kann man das
muss jetzt wahrscheinlich den ersten die
kühltruhe
ich muss mal kurz schoko kit beinhaltet
alles was ihr braucht um euch euren
eigenen schoko snack zu kreieren einfach
die schokoladensauce in der tube in die
mitgelieferte schale füllen die kleine
bizkit kriegsjahren lippen und ab er
wird in den kühlschrank eigentlich schon
geil was andere eltern ist es schon da
kommt also leute wir haben es alle leer
gemacht ich würde mal sagen soll es im
kühlschrank scheinen als hohes gut aber
ich habe gerade schon ein bisschen von
der schoko lose probiert so schmidt sehr
sehr chemisch alter ja das konnte ich
mir schon denken okay
ach so und haben jetzt anscheinend noch
mehr eis so was ja gut wie meine ich die
da bin ich blöd
die kommandanten auch so ein eis drauf
hier die sind da nicht heißt auto dann
heißt drauf meister selbst dass das
nicht mitzieht der ja leute dann würde
ich sagen ich zeige euch jetzt gleich
noch diese gefrorene eis spiele da mit
dem komischen hier mischen zeug drauf
das war's mit den wohl beliebtesten
süßigkeiten aus aller welt 2009/10 es
war ganz interessant für mich eigentlich
ich hoffe euch als auch gefallen lassen
danach um den kanal wir sehen uns dann
am montag vermutlich wieder oder ich
weiß gar nicht wann dieses video kommt
auf jeden fall immer um 19 uhr
haut rein